one of the central arguments of my film
course and this is one of the ways it's
different from a traditional film course
in a film in a universe in a Cinema
Studies program or even in an in an
English department is that it sees the
advent of television as a critical
factor in the history of the movies much
more central and critical than most
contemporary histories acknowledged is
what I try to show is that the function
that the movies had in American society
before the advent of television was the
function that the novel had in the 19th
century in Europe and the function that
Shakespeare's public theatre had in
Shakespeare's day a form of popular
narrative that's articulated a kind of
assumed or imagined consensus of values
for the whole of the society that made
it a culturally and anthropologically
and socially much more important medium
than a mere artistic medium even though
its artistic quality remains very
important so that one of the ironies of
entertainment is that can become a space
especially public forms of entertainment
in cultures like Shakespeare's public
theatre or like the Public Theater of
the American movie system in the studio
era these public spaces can become
spaces in which the body politic the
political and social community
entertains ideas about its own nature
entertains considers speculates holds in
its mind accounts of its origins stories
of its values right and what we can say
then is that the space of entertainment
becomes from in a certain angle in
virtually all societies a space of
discourse a space in which exactly
because it's a space recognized as not
real as make-believe is therefore
licensed or allowed to explore
possibilities that might be too
dangerous or too disturbing to explore
in other way and I taught both
television and film in this way in an
ironic way it's a deeply literal
literary way to teach the medium so the
argument ends up being that the movies
after television the movies after about
1970 are a profoundly
for an animal the old studio system is
dead movies have become much more single
individual deal-making events using
great stars and particularly bankable
script writers and scripts and so forth
nothing like the great factory for the
making of stories the mish the story
machine that that that the movies had
been until the advent of television and
that television became as it took on
that consensus function I think it's a
powerful and central insight that helps
to explain the tremendous changes that
overtake American movies after nineteen
certainly after 1970 and and beyond
another way in which I think my film
course is not fully a film course even
though every text we study is a movie
all the scholarship I cite is movie
scholar not all but some is movie
scholarship and I try to teach them
about the history of film and in ways
that I think are helpful to them but
there is a profoundly literary dimension
to my teaching and I think of it deeply
as a literature course it's a course
that if a student takes serves as a
prerequisite for advanced subjects in
literature as well as in media and my
reasons for that is that I treat the
problems one confronts in a film from
the perspective of a professor of
literature from the perspective of one
who's a specialist in narrative remember
many of the narratives that I team that
I have taught all my life were not
printed texts like novels they were oral
narratives like Homer's Odyssey or they
were dramatic presentations like
Shakespeare's plays literature has never
meant simply printed texts and I think
my field is narrative of all sorts and
what I tried to do is show them among
other things certain kinds of linkages
or continuities across different forms
of narrative and I certainly try to make
them see that movies in a certain era
television in another era were like the
literature of earlier eras and it makes
my film course a much more centrally
literary and humanistic subject than
would be the case if it were taught in a
more conventional kind of Cinema Studies
sequence